what else is going on
in the world what else is happening
on the left side of the political aisle
that's a little bizarre well uh we've
got these high gas prices have you heard
about this and there is this guy
that we're allowed to blame for all of
our problems this vladimir putin guy if
you've got a problem whatever your
problem is you got a bum knee uh you got
a window that's stuck whatever your
problem is in life you got a headache
whatever it might be bad hair day
whatever you blame putin okay you never
take responsibility
that's what they do uh here's pete
buddha judge gay pete he was on fox
business and uh he's very confused about
what's going on here half of that
increase started prior to the first
russian soldiers arriving near ukraine
you can't blame it all on the ukraine
right what about the other half well
what about the other half that's that's
pretty important
your administration has blamed this on
the the you know the war and that was
certainly a big factor but gas prices
had gone up
50
already before the war so to me that's
half of the blame not all the blame
okay so just to be clear once again uh
gay pete who is our transportation
secretary has no expertise in
transportation he was hired because he
was gay that's what they do they love
diversity equity and inclusion you don't
have to be qualified for a job uh much
like our black lesbian press secretary
you don't have to be good at what you do
you just have to have an immutable trait
to get the job our deputy health
secretary rachel levine is trans uh this
is what these people do so you wonder oh
my god why is it that everything seems
like it's collapsing and it's like oh
well are any of the people in charge
qualified for their position or do they
have the mental acumen joe biden to
actually do the job that they're in and
the answer of course is no across the
board uh what pete is not
fully understanding there or fully
admitting is that as i have told you
guys many times gas was up a dollar
fourteen before one troop was in ukraine
before russia did anything with ukraine
gas was already up and
irregardless as the kids say
irregardless of
whether putin went into russia or not it
is the responsibility of any
administration to manage problems you
cannot go oh my god that guy over there
did some bad stuff there's nothing we
can do and if you want to defend the
liberal world order which is what they
keep telling us then yes you're gonna
have to suck it up and pay higher gas
prices and pay higher food prices and
all sorts of stuff no that is not what a
leader does what a leader does is say oh
there's some bad stuff happening over
there
what is it that we can do here what is
within my power
to do here to stop those prices from
going up but biden keeps telling us
we're at war we're at war time nobody
knows really what this war is about by
the way congress of course has not
authorized this war but he keeps telling
us these are not normal times uh and
we've got to just keep giving ukraine
money i do not think we should be giving
ukraine a dime as you know rand paul
basically when they were given 40
billion dollars to ukraine
40 billion dollars and i'm sure that'll
be spent well uh he asked for receipts
just literally basically receipts uh
guys do you have uh microsoft excel can
we do a basic spreadsheet on this so
we're giving you 40 billion how much is
going to french fries can we get some
info here and uh the whole congress they
freaked out the senate and everybody
because they because this is just a
giant swamp grift that's what it is so
of course pete has nothing really to say
there because not only was gas going up
before russia but it's their own
policies and the endless printing of
money you guys get it